can we upset more people a little bit
can you already maybe we try
no no can we uh can I ask you to
elaborate because I my intuition was
that you would be a supporter of
something like cryptocurrency and
Bitcoin because it is fundamentally
emphasizes decentralization what do you
so can you elaborate yeah okay look your
thoughts on bitcoin I um
it's kind of funny
um I I wrote I I've been advocating some
kind of digital currency for a long time
and when the the uh
when when Bitcoin came out and the
original paper on on blockchain
um my heart kind of thing because I
thought oh my God we're applying all of
this fancy thought and all these very
careful distributed security measures
should we create the gold standard like
it's just so retro it's so dysfunctional
it's so useless from an economic point
of view so it's always and then the
other thing is used in computational
inefficiency at a boundless scale as
your form of security is a crime against
this atmosphere obviously a lot of
people know that now but we knew that at
the start like the thing is when when
the first paper came out I remember a
lot of people saying oh my God I think
this thing scales it's a carbon disaster
you know and and
um I I just like I'm just mystified but
that that's a different question than
when you asked can you have
um a cryptographic currency or at least
some kind of digital currency that's of
a benefit and absolutely like I'm and
they're people who are trying to be
thoughtful about this you should uh if
you haven't you should interview vitalik
Buddha in sometimes yeah twice okay so
like there are people in the community
who are trying to be thoughtful and
trying to figure out how to do this
better it has nice properties though
right so that one of the nice problems
is that like government centralized it's
hard to control uh and then the other
one to fix some of the issues that
you're referring to I'm sort of Playing
devil's advocate here is you know
there's lightning Network there's ideas
how do you how you uh build stuff on top
of Bitcoin similar with gold that allow
you to have this kind of vibrant economy
that operates not on the blockchain but
outside the blockchain and uses uh
Bitcoin for uh for like checking the
security of those transactions so
bitcoin's not new it's been around for a
while I've been watching it closely I've
never I've not seen one example of it
creating economic growth there was just
obsession with the idea that government
was the problem that idea that
government's the problem let's say
government earned that wrath honestly uh
because if you look at some of the
things that governments have done in
recent decades it's not a pretty story
like uh after uh after a very small
number of people in the US government
decided to bomb and landmine Southeast
Asia
it's hard to come back and say oh
government's this great thing but uh
then
the problem is that this resistance to
government
is basically resistance to politics it's
a way of saying if I can get rich nobody
should bother me it's a way of not of
not having obligations to others and
that ultimately is a very suspect
motivation but does that mean
that the impulse that the government
um
should not overreach its power is flawed
well I mean what I want to ask you to do
is to replace the word government with
politics
like our politics is people having to
deal with each other but my theory about
freedom is that the only authentic form
of freedom is Perpetual annoyance that
all right so annoyance means you're
actually dealing with people because
people are annoying Perpetual means that
that annoyance is survivable so it
doesn't destroy us all so if you have
Perpetual annoyance then you have
freedom if you have politics that's
politics if you don't have Perpetual
annoyance something's gone very wrong
and you've suppress those people that
it's only temporary it's going to come
back and be horrible you should seek
Perpetual annoyance I'll invite you to a
Berkeley city council meeting so you can
know what that feels like what
professional feels like
but anyway so freedom is being the test
of freedom is that you're annoyed by
other people if you're not you're not
free if you're not you're trapped in
some temporary illusion that's going to
fall apart
now um the this quest to avoid
government is really a quest to avoid
that political feeling but you have to
have it you have to deal with it
um and it sucks but that's the human
situation that's the Human Condition and
this idea that we're going to have this
abstract thing that protects us from
having to deal with each other is always
an illusion the idea and I apologize I'm
uh overstretched the use of the word
government the ideas there should be
some punishment from the people when a
group when a bureaucracy when a set of
when a set of people or a particular
leader like in an authoritarian regime
which more than half the world currently
lives under if you
like if they become they start stop
representing the people it stops being
like a Berkeley uh meeting and starts
being more like uh like a dictatorial
kind of uh situation so the point is
it's it's nice to give people
uh the populist in decentralized way
power to
um resist that kind of uh government
becoming over us yeah but people see
this idea that the problem is always the
government being powerful is false uh
the problem can also be criminal gangs
the problem can also be weird Cults the
problem can be abusive
um abusive clergy the problem can be uh
uh fall infrastructure that fails the
problem can be uh poisoned water the
problem can be failed electric grids the
problem can be
um uh a crappy education system that
makes this the whole society uh less and
less able to to create value there are
all these other problems that are
different from an overbearing government
like you have to keep some sense of
perspective and not be obsessed with
only one kind of problem because then
the others will pop up but empirically
speaking some problems are bigger than
others so like some like groups of
people like governments or gangs or
companies are you a U.S citizen yes has
the government ever really been a
problem for you well okay so first of
all I grew up in the Soviet Union used
to use well and actually yeah my wife
did too yeah so I I have I have seen you
know
um sure uh and has the government
bothered me I would say that uh that's
that's a really complicated question
especially because the United States is
such it's a special place and like like
a like a lot of other countries my
wife's family were refuse Nicks and so
we have like a very and uh her dad was
sent to the gulag uh for what it's worth
uh on my father's side all but a few
were killed by a program in in uh
post-soviet program in Ukraine
because you did a little trick of uh
eloquent trick of language that you
switched to the United States to talk
about government so I am I'm I believe
unlike my friend Michael malice who's an
anarchist I believe go government can do
a lot of good in the world that is
exactly what you're saying which is it's
it's politics the thing that Bitcoin
folks and cryptocurrency folks argue is
that one of the big ways that government
can control the populace is a
centralized Bank like control the the
money that was the case in the Soviet
Union too there's you know uh inflation
is can really make poor people
suffer and so what they argue is this is
one way to go around that power that
government has of controlling the
monetary system so that's a way to
resist that's not actually saying
government bad that's saying some of the
ways that uh central banks get into
trouble can be resisted so let me ask
you on balance today in the real world
in terms of actual facts
do you think cryptocurrencies are doing
more to prop up corrupt murderous
horrible regimes or to resist those
regimes where do you think the balance
is right now I I know exactly uh having
talked to a lot of cryptocurrency folks
what they would tell me right I
it's hard it's
I don't no no no no I'm asking it as a
real question there's no way to know the
answer but there's no way perfectly
however I gotta say uh if you look at
people who've been able to decode uh
blockchains and they they do leak a lot
of data they're not as secure as just
widely thought there are a lot of
unknown uh Bitcoin whales from pretty
early and they're huge and
if you ask who are these people
um there's evidence that a lot of them
are quite on not the people you'd want
to support let's say and I I just don't
like I think empirically this idea that
there's some intrinsic way that bad
governments will
be what will be disempowered and people
will be able to resist them more than
new villains or even villainous
governments will be empowered there's no
basis for that assertion it it just is
kind of circumstantial and uh I think in
general
Bitcoin ownership
is one thing but Bitcoin transactions
have tended to support criminality more
than
productivity of course they would argue
that was that was the story of its early
days that now more and more uh Bitcoin
is being used for uh legitimate
transactions but that's the difference I
didn't say for legitimate transactions I
said for economic growth for for
creativity like um I uh I think what's
happening is people are using it a
little bit for for buying I don't know
maybe somebody's
companies make it available for this and
that they buy a Tesla with it or
something
um
investing in a startup hard it might
have happened a little bit but it's it's
not an engine a productivity creativity
and economic growth uh whereas
old-fashioned currency still is and
uh anyway I'm look I think something
I'm I'm Pro the idea of digital
currencies yeah
I am anti the idea of
economics wiping out Politics As a
result I think they have to exist in
some balance to avoid the worst
dysfunctions of each in some ways
there's parallels to our discussion of
algorithms and cryptocurrency is you're
Pro the idea but it can be used
to manipulate you can use be used poorly
by aforementioned humans well I think
that can make better designs and worse
designs sure and I think and you know
the thing about cryptocurrency that's so
interesting is how many of us are
responsible for the poor designs because
we're all so hooked
on that Horatio Alger story I'm like I'm
gonna be the one who gets the viral
benefit you know way way back when all
this stuff was starting I remember it
would have been in the 80s somebody had
the idea of using viral as a metaphor
for Network effect
and the whole point was to talk about
how bad Network effect was that it
always created distortions that ruined
the the usefulness of economic
incentives that that created dangerous
distortions like but then somehow even
after the pandemic we think of viral as
this good thing because we imagine
ourselves as the virus right we want to
be on the on the beneficiary side of it
but of course you're not likely to be
there is a sense because money is
involved people are not reasoning
uh clearly always because they want to
be they want to be part of that first
viral wave that makes them rich and that
blinds people from their basic morality
I had an interesting conversation I
don't I still feel like I should respect
some people's privacy but some of the
initial people who started uh Bitcoin I
I remember having an argument about like
it's intrinsically a Ponzi scheme like
you know the early people have more than
the later people and the further down
the chain you get the more you're
subject to gambling like Dynamics where
it's more and more random and more and
more subject to weird Network effects
and whatnot unless you're a very small
player uh perhaps then you're just
buying something but even then you'll be
subject to fluctuations because the
whole thing is just kind of it like the
as it fluctuates it's gonna wave around
the little people more and um they and I
remember the conversation turned to
gambling because gambling is a pretty
large economic sector and it's always
struck me as being non-productive like
somebody goes to Las Vegas they lose
money and so one argument is well they
got entertainment they paid for
entertainment as they lost money so
that's fine and the in Las Vegas does up
the losing of money in an entertaining
way so why not it's like going to a show
so that's one argument the argument that
was made to me was different from that
is that no what they're doing is they're
getting a chance to experience hope and
a lot of people don't get that chance
and so that's really worth it even if
they're going to lose they have that
moment of Hope and they need to be able
to experience that and this is a very
interesting argument
um that's so heartbreaking because well
but I've seen that like that I have that
a little bit of a sense I've talked to
some young people who invest in
cryptocurrency
and it that what I see is this hope this
is the first thing they gave them hope
and that's so heartbreaking to me
that you've gotten Hope from the so much
is invested it's like Hope from somehow
becoming rich as opposed to something to
me I apologize but money is in the long
term not going to be a source of that
deep meaning it's good to have enough
money but it should not be the source of
Hope and it's heartbreaking to me how
many people it's a source of Hope
yeah um
you've just described the psychology of
virality or the psychology of of trying
to raise a civilization on semi-random
occurrences of network effect Peaks